wir wollen noch mal schauen auf bilder
von der russischen botschaft hier in
berlin ob sich dort vor ort was tut
peter thiede ist natürlich weiterhin bei
uns im studio peter vielleicht wollen
wir nochmal drüber sprechen die
russische botschaft eine baustelle wie
wir hier sehen noch haben sich dort
keine menschen versammelt erwartest du
dass da was passiert im laufe des tages
und wie sieht eigentlich aus mit der
russischen bevölkerung die es ja sehr
wahrscheinlich auch gespalten wo es laut
ist ein riesenland wer steht eigentlich
hinter putin und wer nicht vor der
russischen botschaft mit meiner
erfahrung nach nicht so viel passieren
die gleichgültigkeit in deutschland wie
sie von konflikt und das verständnis für
für russland ist leider gottes verdammt
hoch viel zu hoch für mich völlig
unverständlich auch nach allen den
aggression und und in russland haben wir
eine stark veränderte situation die hat
sich in den letzten jahren dramatisch
verändert wladimir putin hat eben land
aufgeräumt wladimir putin hat die
opposition ausgeschaltet weekend alexei
navalny der ermordet werden sollte er
vergiftet werden sollte der im gulag
sitzt wir kennen erschossen wie die
oppositionsführer in jedem zoff
die die kreml brücke auf der die
gedenkstätte für wen ist heißt unter den
leuten die bei den kritischen soft
brücke games of post gibt es auch im
einen anstecker andere oppositionelle
wären wir oder kowski waren im oder
putin kritiker waren im gulag sind
enteignet von kasparov sitzt im ausland
gegen janko ist ermordet worden und im
land hat er die medien gleichgeschaltet
es gibt in russland quasi keine freien
medien kennen die norway engagiert die
den nobelpreis bekommen hat die er
scheint noch dreimal in der woche aber
in den regionen im tv und im radio gibt
es im prinzip bis auf ein prozent keine
freien medien die sind gleichgeschaltet
sind oligarchen putin an die gleichen
zugeordnet worden oder aber den
gazprom-konzern für den hier unser
altkanzler gerhard schröder so glorreich
arbeitet das ist eins der wichtigsten
werkzeuge zur gleichschaltung von
elektronischen medien von radio und tv
stationen im land und gerade von lokal
stadt station gazprom media ist eines
der wesentlichen werkzeuge und du christ
freunde von von moskau hören kein
autoradio weil sie angst haben dass
irgendetwas von dieser propaganda bein
hängen bleibt wir sehen hier aktuelle
bilder die kommen aus dem grenzgebiet
und zu denen zudem setzen und jetzt
anerkannten gebieten in ende in der ost
ukraine da fahren die panzer vor ich war
genau in der region vor vor etwa drei
wochen und habe mich mit den leuten vor
ort da hat das ist natürlich eine
militär region aber
mehr als 60 prozent der russen sind
inzwischen der meinung sie hätten gerne
die sowjetunion wieder die trauer nach
all der propaganda dieser seit jahren
auf sie nieder prasselt trauern sie der
groß- und sowjetunion sie empfinden also
jedenfalls den phantomschmerz ihres
kreml führer solar die mir putin der
sender so weit so dermaßen hinterher
trauert den empfinden sie inzwischen
nach und sie empfinden und sagen uns
auch ganz offen die wirklich die
mehrheit der russen mit dem mann spricht
dass da sind bedrohte russen im gebiet
der ost ukraine das ist ein bruder voll
wir wollen keinen krieg und dann kommt
das typische aber und die müssten
verteidigt werden wir haben ja auch
gerade schon bilder gesehen wie die
soldaten wirklich fröhlich in die kamera
winken skurril absurd regelrechte man
hat das gefühl die freuen sich die
fühlen sich als befreier das ist aber
auch das bild das ihm eingetrichtert
wird das ist das geschichtsbild dass
wladimir putin ja wieder beliebt also
wir haben tatsächlich es ist für
menschen die aus dem kalten krieg kommen
wirklich unvorstellbar fallen darin
zurück in die rhetorik das sind nicht
wir das ist nicht der westen das ist
wladimir putin der fällt in die rhetorik
zurück und richtet den leuten ein dass
da ein faschistisches system in kiew
ethnischen russen bedroht das muss man
sich auf der zunge zergehen lassen auf
das bitter schmeckt er erfindet gerade
die russische rasse er behauptet dass
der russische menschen oder menschen die
russisch fühlen bedroht werden also er
sagt jeder der russe spricht kann von
uns im ausland verteidigt werden das
gibt übrigens auch die
sicherheitsdoktrin die vor ein paar
jahren geändert worden ist hier russland
der kreml darf soldaten in jedes land
schicken wo man meint dass russen oder
russischsprachige oder russisch fühlende
menschenbild bedroht werde schauen wir
mal ins land wir haben bilder aus moskau
vorliegen jetzt peter dohmen anordnen
muss bilder von aktuelle bilder von
heute morgen die wir ihnen jetzt mal
zeigen wollen meine damen und herren wir
es gerade jedenfalls über unseren
magischen knopf ins ohr gesagt wenn die
bilder noch den 1 die entscheidung wurde
getroffen um den frieden zu festigen und
die sicherheit der menschen in den volks
republiken lugansk und und jetzt zu
schützen es ist das beste was man für
die menschen tun kann
die entscheidung dass trotz einiger
nachwirkungen richtig gewesen die frage
der anerkennung der unabhängigkeit und
souveränität von lukas und dann jetzt
hat sich schon vor langer zeit gestellt
schließlich dauert der konflikt schon
acht jahre
tatsächlich gibt es keinen ausweg aus
dem konflikt die beiden seiten haben
versucht zu verhandeln aber es wurde
nichts daraus am ende hat der russische
präsident eine entscheidung getroffen
mir scheint dass es im moment
wahrscheinlich die einzige lösung ist
obwohl es konsequenzen haben wird es
keine sanktionen geben die das leben der
menschen beeinträchtigen aber jede
entscheidung hat ihre vor und nachteile
und ich denke so ist es das richtige
ist also genauso wie du vorhin
eingeordnet hast wir müssen dann nehmen
wir dann jetzt noch mehr einordnen weil
das mikrofon dass wir da gesehen haben
das ist von einem chinesischen
staatssender ist ja im prinzip zu einer
art kommunistische cnn es ist der
englischsprachige service unterstützte
der chinesischen kommunistischen partei
und wenn jeder auf die straße gehen dann
kriegen sie auch die entsprechenden die
entsprechenden einfachen aber die
mehrheit der russen denkt auch nach
unabhängigen befragung es gibt ja noch
lewada institut das ist das letzte
halbwegs unabhängige befragung das
institut meinungsforschungsinstitut dass
es gibt auch gebrandmarkt als
ausländischer agent übrigens wie alles
was nicht auf linie ist und meine
erfahrung ist dass ganz viele russen
auch wieder in gang zurück gefallen sind
aus der alten sowjet zeit aus passion
fruits of stadien seiten gehen so durchs
leben die gucken nicht nach oben die
sagen da oben das ist politik wenn man
wenn man die nach bestimmten themen
fragt man sagen die das ist politik ich
kümmere mich nicht darum die gucken da
nicht hin und die haben angst auch ihre
meinung zu sagen also die leute die
anders denken
sagen ihre meinung auch nicht mehr offen
wie jeweils nicht auf dem land wir haben
unter der studentenschaft und unter den
jungen leuten in den großstädten eine
andere klientel
da da da sind leute die sind nicht daran
interessiert das ist bei jungen leuten
anders sie sind nicht daran interessiert
jetzt die neuen amg mercedes zu fahren
oder irgendwie reich zu werden oder den
besten teuersten urlaub zu machen das
sind idealisten die hat man ja in
russland auch wenn die von der politik
getroffen werden wenn die sich ungerecht
behandelt fühlen reißen die sich ja die
brust auf das ist typisch russisch das
ist das was wir kennen die reißen sich
dann die brust bauch und dann werden sie
mutig und
aber die mehrheit und das gehört leider
dazu ist geprägt von dem was man da 24
stunden sieben tage die woche staats-tv
staatsradios staatszeitung oder
oligarchen zeitungen oder tv und radio
hört geprägt und das ist das
erschütternde dass das freie russland
das was ein optimal stolz gemacht hat
was einem das herz erwärmt hatte mal
hingefahren ist erschossen im gulag oder
im ausland oder traut sich nicht mehr
richtig auf die straße ist ja auch genau
da wo man sich halt gerade sagen sie
würden die menschen auf die straße gehen
also dass es für dich völlig
ausgeschlossen da ist es bei
demonstrationen
dass es da sogar eine revolte geben kann
das ist der unterschied und zwar
wirklich einen mann kann ist in der luft
für moskau und kiew nach moskau gehst
hast du eine fröhliche eine ganz andere
stimmung und in russland hast du einfach
eine andere stimmung es ist nicht so
offen und verschließt sich immer mehr
und russland wird leider gottes wieder
zu hause und fand sich aber wo sind die
friedensdemonstrationen hier bei uns
natürlich auch keinen krieg wollen das
ist aber eben auch älter geben da werden
nur ganz kurz einmal dazu weil die
deutsche friedensbrücke sie haben sich
eine täter ist
können wir darüber sprechen
wir haben paul ronzheimer in der leitung
der live vor ort ist dort an der front
momentan paul
thomas es ist wie in den vergangenen
tagen auf wir haben immer wieder
anschläge gehört auf dieser seite und es
ist eine unheimliche situation muss man
sagen dort hier mitten zwischen diesen
dörfern sind die verschiedenen
positionen und wir hören von beiden
seiten einschläge der separatisten und
wir hören auch ausgehende einschläge in
der vergangenen stunde von der
ukrainischen armee es ist ein bisschen
geisterhafte stimmung kann man fast
sagen hier in diesem dorf in dem wir
gerade stehen jederzeit kann es wieder
einen angriff geben wir haben mit
soldaten sprechen können sie sehen
frustriert aus sie sind traurig aus sie
wollen kaum reden ich glaube sie haben
verstanden das ist jetzt ein
möglicherweise großer krieg auf sie
zukommen könnte dass die ukraine weitere
gebiete hier verlieren könnte
paul vielleicht magst du mal ganz kurz
erklären wo stehst du da genau du
sprichst von einem dorf wie viele
menschen befinden sich da momentan
ich bin insasse war das ist ein kleines
dorf ich zeige euch mal hier ein
bisschen die situation wie sie aussieht
das sind verschiedene häuser man hört
aus dem hintergrund die einschläge der
mörsergranaten und das ist das womit
viele
hin müssen die in diesen häusern gerade
ihr versteck suchen die ihnen den
kellern sitzen sie haben kein strom da
sind kerzen an in diesen häusern und es
kann jederzeit passieren dass wieder
eine granate dass der mörserbeschuss
losgeht
paul wir sprechen uns nachher wieder
bleibt bitte bleib bitte dort und passt
gut auf dich auf peter tiede bei uns
hier im studio peter bevor wir in die
werbung geht ganz kurz noch das wort
wohl sind die friedensdemonstrationen
die deutsche friedensbewegung das ist
teil der bitteren wahrheit der man sich
irgendwie stellen muss war immer an der
seite russlands oder der sowjetunion war
in wesentlichen teilen auch schlicht und
ergreifend davon steuert wir erinnern
uns also die älteren unter uns erinnern
sich noch an die generelle für den
frieden und die ostermärsche die stadt
gefunden gegen die russischen raketen
die haben aber gegen diese wette schon
als atomwaffen im wesentlichen
stattgefunden gingen die amerikanischen
und den nato doppelbeschluss und wir
haben diese friedensbewegung in
deutschland schlicht und ergreifend auf
der straße keine tradition und für die
freiheit tatsächlich einzusetzen wir
haben uns zumindest der westen
deutschlands hat sich 40 jahre lang
schön beschützen lassen von den
amerikanern von den franzosen und von
den briten wir sind zu ähnlichen
leistungen nicht in der lage nicht
bereit und da fehlt uns eine tradition
und damit fehlt uns auch ein ganzes
stück wirklich demokratische
grundhaltung die ich die ich wirklich
vermisse wir müssen nicht mit soldaten
denn gehen wir müssen nicht zwingend
dabei kann man wirklich diskutieren dass
ein strittiges thema ich bin dafür aber
man muss keine waffen liefern aber man
muss sich doch verdammt noch mal auch
mal auf die beine machen können und
nicht nur gegen düsseldorf gesehen
demonstrieren können sondern auch mal
für die freiheit und für menschenrechte
und für unsere werte aber die tradition
führt bei uns vielen dank peter tiede
für den moment für deine einschätzungen
und auch eine klare haltung und seine
klaren worte